how to grow as an artist is to is to do
things that you don't know how to do
right today I'm speaking with the very
talented Zoe Lister Jones so hey Mr
Jones everyone
sitcom Life In Pieces Band-Aid the movie
She stars in in May you're in a new film
called Beau is a freight she's in
theaters Nationwide writer a producer a
director and an actor it's nice to wear
so many different hats you know because
they're all different muscles to flex
today we dive into the creative process
behind Zoe's newest creation slip the
binge-worthy comedy series that involves
parallel realities and Alternate
identities we talk about making deeply
authentic work the responsibility she
shoulders to empower other women in the
Arts it's always a friend she is a star
very much on the rise and an artist in
the absolute truest sense of the word
[Music]